una firma pero ningún apretón de manos
entre los representantes sudaneses de
los dos bandos
reunidos en jetda Arabia Saudita
llegaron a un acuerdo el jueves por la
noche para despejar los corredores de
evacuación de la población civil así
como el ingreso de la ayuda humanitaria
pero tras seis días de negociaciones no
se ha anunciado un nuevo César fuego
los combates siguen causando estragos en
la capital harton en este vídeo
aficionado soldados de las fuerzas de
acción rápida el grupo paramilitar
opuesto al ejército regular se filman
apoderándose de varios tanques y
vehículos en el norte de la ciudad en el
suelo Cuerpo sin vida yacen en medio de
la carretera ambos bandos se acusan
mutuamente matar a civiles
la vida se ha convertido en un infierno
para los que siguen en el país
la guerra ha hecho que las condiciones
de vida sean extremadamente duras en
jartum la mayoría de las tiendas han
cerrado la gente tiene grandes
dificultades para conseguir comida
harton está literalmente
sus reservas viajar Es muy arriesgado y
mucho más caro con la explosión de los
precios del combustible
todas las gasolineras están fuera de
servicio Aunque hay combustible pero
solo se vende en el mercado informal un
galón que normalmente se vende a unos 5
dólares Vale ahora casi 60 dólares a
falta de una nueva tregua continúan las
negociaciones dirigidas por Estados
Unidos y Arabia Saudita que esperan
lograr un cese al fuego de 10 días para
poder entregar toda la ayuda humanitaria